so today we're gonna be swapping some
snacks I've brought some Australian Zac
I'm representing Team American snacks
it's like more kids in grade school
where you're like would you break but
lokay I feel like ah snacks Abed I'm not
even a competition American snacks are
very all very salty yeah I've got a lot
of stuff we do we'll see who's better
okay America Australia USA today a us so
right here I have RIT's this is very
classic we're gonna complain about the
cheese because it's not like real
probably I have shakes these are so
iconic keep putting a ball at a party
well you just like sit on your couch
Nate them out of the box really it kind
of just smell like pizza it's very
subtle it's not too in-your-face biscuit
itself is nice like it's nice and
buttery biscuit but the cheese is like
the cheese that you get in a burger at
McDonalds look I would eat this yes I
just don't understand why it's sweet if
sweet it is sweet no it's not
look I don't hate it but I definitely
cheese yeah this is good this is good
although I do prefer the original Ritz
I think shites are definitely better
than Ritz crackers I think at a party I
would I wouldn't rather some shapes
premium handi-snacks you're gonna dip a
little mini breadstick into the cheese
so have fun so even more orange cheese
this is another flavor of shapes chicken
cream PD chicken is actually my favorite
food that's an interesting favorite food
to have really yeah she can do like an
ingredient any chicken yeah okay
this doesn't taste like chicken this
just tastes like weird salt I must leave
does not taste like chicken but I like
this better look I'm really concerned
about this texture together more real
than the one
I was a kid I would love this like if I
got this in my lunchbox at school I'd be
really into it these are really hot like
you know chicken cream pea shapes a
hundred and ten percent better than me I
like this better than pizza one so this
is definite my favorite so far there it
is Lunchables the most basic the most oh
gee this every kid's dream I don't know
if this is a snack this is a whole-day
meal all I have for you is chicken chips
which if you didn't like the crackers I
don't know more chicken flavored salty
things why oh this is good hey does this
that check anything
it's a solid chip if you're really into
chicken flavored ramen highly recommend
are you missed eight disco yeah let me
just uh move your hands
yeah oh it's a version oh I feel like a
little chef the fun is like you could
put as much or as little on of whatever
ingredient this is what I meant by
shredded cheese make it truly feels like
rub ah but this is this is what I like
though shredded cheese oh I'm ready okay
I noticed that she put more white cheese
on them yellow cheese you are making
such a face
don't hurt my fault this bread is like I
don't know what's happening it's like so
soft and pillowy and like doughy the
bread uh-huh
it's a roll paint job why would you want
that but I think it would be better if
you just have a sandwich the piece de
resistance pup reason if you're not a
sugar lover watch out it's pretty cool
it's like a patch of gypsum I had
probably like five persons per day when
I was young yeah
[Music]
I kind of like it no way that'd be a
good mixed drink yeah say this is vodka
I don't think they're quite the same but
if we had to compare I'm gonna go with
lunchable because eligibles oh this yes
good how's this yeah I think I'm also
gonna say Lunchables win just because
you get a drink a dessert and you get to
make your own food where this is just
like you're eating chips yeah
Twizzlers iconic classic get it with
your popcorn at the movies well on the
flip side this is like my favorite loli
that we have in Australia
these are Rob's related so I feel like
raspberries just that fruit that's like
it's all little better yeah yeah this
looks like fake candy that doesn't look
like it should be consumed by a human
this doesn't taste like anything they
have like the faintest flavor strawberry
but like it's just like you're eating
like plastic I would assume trailers are
red flavored this kind of tastes the
same guys that one that has flavor
though ate one of those and then tell me
that that again does it oh nevermind
thank you why are you so hard to chew
you do have to work that hard for every
single gummy piece Oh God no these
people like this you will like this no I
would say Twizzlers are better because
they don't give you such a tough time
they taste like nothing but also you're
sitting there and you're like well
that's what these are Tara what's a
little bit more of nothing this is a
good comparison
[Music]
sour patch kids my favorite candy if you
don't like this candy I'm gonna like be
very sad this this all different five
bucks in high school which is ridiculous
overpriced but I still bought it
these are cherry ripe switch I feel like
in Australia is thought of as like the
old person chocolate real cherries dark
chocolate coconut I feel like you're
gonna like me
I think I will yeah this is very glossy
glossy packaging which is the best color
mine was yellow
no yellows never the best flavor of
anything really yellows are always the
best no red oh nice nice breakage mmm oh
good mesh with us this is good stuff so
is this I really like this they off
salabat you know sweet way I see what
you mean by like American got me it's
like easy to choose right because I
could let you just put this in my mouth
and swallow and I wouldn't die yeah I'm
look like you need more than one of this
really sweet yeah cuz no may I come in a
Bob that's like this big these are just
like the fun size is big yeah Wow
but like now the question is like which
one is better this so different it's
like they're so different I almost want
to just like call it a draw and be like
they're both real good I'm happy to draw
this one somebody choice is hard pitch
for sure Jack I really love these yellow
I'm good I'm eating the other one I
[Music]
loved cashews as I can't although
preface haven't had them in ages when
you really think about what this is it's
weird but so good fantail so basically
just caramel covered in chocolate the
idea is that like H fantail has Moody
trivia on the packaging other okay so
it's kind of like movies Oh Oh
interesting
the only thing about these is that they
are really hot and chewy if you lose a
tooth it's not on me that's like a
problem then you should go back and fix
the food will enjoy this is very splashy
alright that's a very interesting way to
do it it's not oh it's really sticky
inside he is sometimes the flavor of the
gushes out of Laura Lee okay well you
cheese oh man before I hard
it's up to my taste it's good but it's
very hard to gain we feel hard to eat
I'm worried for my chase right now but
does it taste good just kind of fake
tasting I think I'd like it as a kid but
I do like the gush it's not quite a gosh
it's more of a squirt so I've had like
three different ones of these and they
all just taste the same yeah he's an
overlying taste quality if you like
chocolate and you like caramel and you
like fun facts about celebrities perfect
and if you like sugar you're not bad
your match well of all of the Australian
snacks my favorite was definitely the
pizza shapes those are good yeah the top
hatch gets a good but overall I feel
like a show you definitely has the
better snacks I'm sorry
I feel like Austria necks also cater to
adults where a versus the American snack
that I showed you is for kids only yeah
good in different ways yeah definitely
it depends on what you're craving and
what your tastes are and what your age
is that's also true yeah but now I
honestly like had to mature so I need to
like have a nap or something
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]